all right so Loki season 2 is cheetah
release next year with production on the
series already well underway Marvel have
been showing lots of secret trailers
behind the scenes at special fan events
and so far we've tried to cover them all
what about Loki season 2 is something
that we still haven't touched upon but
my uncle attended an event back well not
my uncle someone else I know attended an
event back in September which had the
full trailer shown at it in this video
we're going to be breaking it all down
and going over our theories on what's
happening in the series it's Siri time's
Siri time series now we have seen from
some recent d23 trailers that they have
some different things in them to what
gets put out publicly for example
quantumania had Kang asking Scott if
he'd kill them before which is a line
that didn't make it to the one that
dropped online still though this will
probably be at least 60 to 70 percent of
what gets released in the final public
one along with a couple of extra shots
that might not make it I also want to
talk about some of the Deadpool 3 rumors
and a report about one of the characters
going into that movie from Loki because
of that full spoilers ahead and if you
don't want some of the surprises ruined
then I recommend that you turn off now
but out of the way thank you for
clicking the video now let's get into
Loki season two okay so from what I see
sorry what my uncle well my uncle's
friend scene of the trailer it opens
with an elevator ping huge it out
singing rock stars are pointing out that
this is similar to how the trailer for
season one opened as well
this then opens up showing the Marvel
Studios logo which is of course
mimicking the elevators in the TVA it
also has clock gears and pieces in the
background this then shifts to the
classic Marvel red with the Studio's
logo staying over the top of it from
here we go to the TVA Lobby and see Loki
curiously walking towards someone
reading a burgundy manual this has the
TVA logo on it but sadly we don't see
the person who's holding it Loki looks
really confused over what's going on and
my guess is that he's extremely
Bamboozled over this can control TVA no
one other than him seems to notice
anything's wrong and if you cast your
mind back to the ending of season one it
seemed like he'd ended up in an
alternate timeline that was controlled
by the villain this was something that
was warned by he who remains who said
that the Multiverse would ultimately
lead to his variants being created
however leaks on the show have said this
is actually a bit of a misdirect and
that Loki is still in the original
timeline that he was in season one now
technically he's not in the 616 because
he broke off into another timeline when
escaping Avengers Tower and end game
that's going to be something that's
meant to be explored in the series with
it being revealed that he's still in the
same universe that he was always in
whether this has been altered by Kanga
Selby remains to be seen and you know
what it might not even be true the
bloody leaks again they are always full
of [ __ ] but I thought I'd just bring
that up in case it turns out to be true
now we do see Sylvie later on by herself
sitting on a couch sprawled out with
headphones on much in the same way that
he who remains at his own office it
seems like this is where she's now
sitting about potentially looking over
everything anyway Loki says a louder the
person reading the book and then all of
a sudden he warps out of there and into
another part of the TVA he's in a much
darker environment here with most of the
power cut out though there are some
things flickering up the TVA seems
completely empty and from here we get a
cut to where he's standing amongst some
sand dunes this could be the girl be
there said that he crash landed in
during season one and they might be kind
of revisiting that location education to
see if he can trace back his steps over
the top of this we hear him saying that
this is going to sound strange and he
explains that he's been pulled through
time we then watch him walking along a
corridor with him jumping back and forth
it's sort of like when he was rewinding
Hana B15 in season 1 and he skips about
between places this is clearly someone
using a temp pad on him which could be
Kang just toying with the character I
don't know if this will be the same Kang
as the one in Quantum Mania as from what
I've heard on the leaks they they don't
line up if you want to see our breakdown
on that movie then it will be linked on
screen right now but we are going to be
dealing with multiple kangs in the MCU
and I think this one's separate of him
and now we start to explore more of the
TVA including a circular room with TVs
lettering the wall it's sort of like the
architect ones from The Matrix but it's
mixed with a sort of factory control
terminal lots of green among State and
he explains to whoever he's talking to
that he's seen terrible and awful things
it's difficult to make out where he is
when he said saying this but it appears
to be a similar room to the one he got
judged in by ravona rensslayer if that's
the case then he's probably been pulled
back through the TVA and once more he's
being judged by one of the judges we
then cut to him standing beside one of
the murals in the TVA Lobby and on that
we can clearly see the timekeepers he
then hits this with one of the TVA
eraser sticks and just like when a
timeline got taken out does that erase
your effect going over the top of it
like it's basically wiping out what was
there this reveals that there's actually
three heads beneath it similar to the
way the timekeeper ones were displayed
in season one however instead of the
timekeepers it's actually Jonathan
major's face demonstrating Kang is now
behind it all Loki then says that war is
on the way and this is of course
referencing the multiversal war that was
teased at the start of season one with
him is morbius sorry Mobius I'm probably
gonna call Mobius Mobius about 20 times
in this video but we're making a point
here that I'm meaning Mobius every time
I say it and not and not the gray
greatest comic book movie of all time
and Mobius seems shocked to see this
playing out and then we get a title
screen saying next summer teasing out
when season 2 could be starting up from
here we cut to another section of the
TVA that we haven't seen before it looks
like a Bookshop with a circular desk in
the middle and operating this as a clerk
played by none other than kehu Kwan he's
been smashing through the Multiverse and
everything everywhere all at once and
he's gonna be what appears to be either
a library archivist or something else is
archivist a word anyway looks like Casey
might actually have been replaced by him
as we get a quick cut of him in the
dusty prison being led through it now it
might even be possible that we learn the
origin story of the TBA agents season
one showed us that rovona rensslayer was
a teacher and we know the whole jet ski
story with Mobius which just give that
man a jet ski the shot with Casey could
potentially be showing his life before
he was picked up as we see Hunter B15 in
the following shot wearing normal
clothes this is in the style of an
African dress s with her wearing a
headscarf and rings around her neck this
is the first time we've seen her out of
uniform and in season one she had a
brief moment where she remembered her
life before the TVA potentially we could
end up seeing that and if we're eating
more into the MCU law then it might be
possible she's from wakanda now I think
all the TVA agents are actually variants
that were taken by the company and
reformatted into their staff we saw them
basically trying to do that with a Loki
variant in season 1 and whilst his main
version was continuing in the 616 they
were using him to help track down Selby
we also see ravana in what looks like a
TVA interrogation room and this could be
following on from her leaving at the end
of the last season in case you don't
know ravona is seen as the love of
Kang's life and in his recently rebooted
origin story he bumped into several
versions of her lay throughout time he's
always been destined to watch her die
though or have her turn on him unless he
spent the entirety of his life depressed
and alone it looks like The Season's
gonna be full of big locations too and
we see what looks like a movie premiere
or the red sports car outside of it
Mobius comes out wearing a tuxedo and
the trailer ends with this location as
well we then see that there's two
versions of Loki both wearing tuxedos we
also have a new TVA location which looks
like the inside of a train station I've
got no idea what that is probably you
probably should see if screen Crush have
a breakdown and instead of something
because yeah no no idea that where this
was in the leaks but let me know below
if you saw it and you know aloki is also
fighting TVA agents here and he smacks
one which makes a green glow emanate
from them we see Loki getting chased
through an Alleyway and a Truck almost
reverses into him from here we get Quick
Cuts of the TV8 offices and some of
their clerks along with things like the
tape recorders one of the staff members
is Liz Carr who's rocking a TVA higher
UPS uniform we also see Mobius wearing
what looks like a space suit before we
watch Loki falling through the white
void that the TVA exists in if you
haven't really seen outside of this and
where it is and if there's even a flaw
for him to fall into now lastly the
teaser ends with Loki and Mobius sitting
in a room together and Mobius basically
says how he's not the bad guy Loki says
he is and then lists off all the people
who've said that this includes the
Avengers Phil Coulson Miss minutes and
Thanos as well so nice little joke to
end the teaser and it spells out that
we're going to be going over bits of
Loki's past too interestingly we didn't
ever see Thanos calling him a bad guy so
maybe we'll get a reference to what
happened between the pair before he sent
him to Earth in The Avengers you also
have some behind the scenes images that
show on McDonald's in the 70s with
Sylvia appearing like she might be
working there I'm loving it and perhaps
she's decided to actually go and just
have a normal life instead of being she
who remains the shot of her on the couch
had a listening to 70s records so I'm
guessing that this scene is just
building off the back of that she was of
course hounded for her whole life by the
TVA so maybe now she just wants to relax
listen to Abba and be become a dancing
queen in the 70s you could say she's
Bjorn again
now as for the Deadpool 3 News Daniel
rpk reported that Mobius would be a big
character in the film Owen Wilson will
be reprising his role and this gives us
some Clues as to what that movie's about
now it's already become pretty clear
that the version of Wolverine will see
in that film won't be the one from Logan
he died at the end of that movie and
Hugh Jackman has made it clear he
doesn't want to wreck on that instead
this will be a Multiverse version of the
character Mobius might even be the one
who guides both him and Wade Wilson
through the entire MCU it's even
possible that the TVA are pulled in two
Logan was supposed to die at the end of
that film then a version of him
surviving could be a timeline that needs
to be pruned sure the Multiverse is open
now but they might still want to clean
up some timelines that could pose a
threat to Kang Wolverine and Deadpool
would definitely be two people that Kang
would want out the way because they're
the kind of people who just mess
everything up who knows what's going
going on though but I do find it
interesting that Mobius is coming across
too wow will Owen Wilson be a big
addition to that movie and if he's in it
then season two probably sets up that
film we better get Wolverine walking out
of a Portland saying I'm back you [ __ ]
but let me know below what you think
will happen in the film anyway that's
the video and I hope that you enjoyed it
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
so make sure you comment below and let
me know if you are in a competition
right now and giving away three copies
of House of the Dragon season 1 on the
15th of December and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the trailer
you pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now save
that to you then message me on Twitter
at hippies spoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of the
original script for wakanda forever
which will be linked on screen right now
we've gone over all the details we have
on the film so definitely head over
there right after this by the way thanks
for saying you the video I've been poor
I'll see you next time take care peace